yeah yeah this Cassidy The Hustler you
already know how I carry it and check me
out right now on bootleg Kev podcast
it's crazy let's get it easy
podcast man special guest in here
Cassidy
welcome thanks for having me ball listen
uh you are one of my favorite rappers
bro like when I was a kid man listen how
about split personality I'm a hustler
bars all that [__] man I appreciate you
man I always say when it comes to like
did it without you if you ain't buy it I
wouldn't have sold out on records yo
listen when it comes to like punch lines
I always say it's you and Lloyd Banks as
the goats man that's odd Yeah man so
it's good to see you brother I'm just
happy I'm in the conversation you know
everybody have a different um
group of people they put me in the
conversation with but I'm just happy I'm
in it all the time what was that
something about the best punches and
then you had that you had that record
where you was the intro where you was
battling yourself yeah I got another one
too I just did um ARP rbe Rare Breed
entertainment he hosted it okay came to
the stew through some money on the
ground for me to battle myself and I did
a new one so it'll be awesome what was
that the Hustler versus the what was the
name of that record
I did two of them it was the intro on
one of your albums where you was like it
was the Hustler versus the on the bars
album and um I'm a hustle album yeah man
crazy man one time I did the problem
versus The Hustler that's the one I'm
thinking we have the Hustler versus bars
well listen man it's good to have you
here
um
you've been doing a lot of battling too
lately
yeah yeah I'm back man I'm backing up in
the ring in my bag it got me feeling
young again you know that's how I
started doing music battling being
competitive so it's helping me get back
to my roots I was gonna say for you is
it like you've had such a long journey
through music
um
do you do you feel like because I feel
like when when people see some of these
lineups right and I was just talking to
uh Ness about this like I'm like like
the battle rap world is such a like
Niche hip-hop space that like people can
be like real hardcore hip-hop heads and
really not be super tapped into what's
going on in the battle world you know
what I'm saying of course it's his own
it's his own Universe man right you know
man and you're like a name to where if
you're on the flyer like anybody is oh
that's Cassidy you know what I'm saying
like you're bringing eyes to that world
that maybe not would have checked it out
otherwise you know what I'm saying so
you're finding it easy for you to thrive
in that space in terms of like because
you're bringing like you're kind of
bringing a lot of eyes to it so I'm sure
you could charge more than most people
yeah like that lane that former battle
rap I started it like nobody never
really seen that form of battle rap
before they seen me in the freeway
battle which is legendary you might have
heard about it especially if he wasn't
really in the industry and super
connected you might have heard about it
but you never actually got a chance to
see it especially on camera right so
that was the first time people got a
chance to see like somebody face to face
being competitive snap into no beat and
like to no real flow like just talking
to each other that was the first time
people really got to see it so that's
that paved the way to all of these
leagues starting so I felt like I
started all of this right and um I
inspired like
um
99.9 percent of the people that do it to
do it if not a hundred percent so that's
the reason why I feel like I deserve the
money I run things and when I come back
I shake it up and that's why that part
of the culture respond like they do when
I'm back because they know the work I
put in yeah yo the neither you battle
freeway give me the background of that
night because was it he they were on Hot
97 that night or something yeah earlier
that night yeah and then Swiss was like
I got because obviously freeway's from
Philly you're from Philly so that
happened at a recording studio
yeah so did you pull up knowing y'all
were gonna battle
and did he know you guys were gonna
battle
no I was already in the studio and I
went to McDonald's when I heard them on
the radio rapping and talking about they
want to battle and
anybody could get it so they wasn't
talking about me but I felt like they
was right so when I got back to the
studio
um I told Swiss about it and he like I
don't matter Jay-Z coming to a studio
tonight anyway
so I'm just sitting around doing Jay-Z
got there he introduced them to me
introduced me as like
him like the next one yeah and Jay-Z
took offense today like what you ain't
hit my artist I got the hottest [__]
and that's how I started getting
competitive Who start talking he called
them up we called out peoples up next
thing you know the studio was crowded
and we battled oh man that was a
legendary moment man yeah
um I'd heard that you guys were supposed
to run it back it just didn't end up
getting worked out
yeah we're supposed to be with the URL
with smack where you're supposed to do
another one but I don't know
business-wise it ain't just didn't line
up yeah that's fair yeah that was a I
feel like that because correct me if I'm
wrong but that came out did that video
come out like right away or was it like
later on that we actually saw the video
hmm nah it took some time at first at
first it was um
it was on audio like a DJ got a copy of
the tape and put it on audio so a lot of
people only they just had it on Napster
Moody was like download battles off
Napster I think it was even before that
time because it was on VHS team so the
DJ put it on you know CD on mixtape and
that's how people started to hear it
around you know around the world they
was hearing the audio but didn't see the
visual and um
it was floating around in the industry
certain key people got a chance to see
the visual but the internet wasn't out
it was like folklore it was like it was
like some Word of Mouth [__] like yo I
saw this tape that that [__] don't exist
I know I saw it yeah exactly and it was
no YouTube no internet for people to
really get access to it so
it was just like big on the streets and
building up for a long period of time
and then when YouTube and the internet
dropping everything then they
re-uploaded it and people started
getting to see it all around the world
yeah no legendary man so you uh take me
back to
obviously the full surface era was crazy
uh you had three great bodies of work
hit records all of that
what was it like running around in
Arizona with DMX and swiss beats in the
early 2000s bro yeah it was it was dope
man it was fun man for people who don't
know Swiss beats had kind of like
planted his feet pretty heavy out in AZ
he was a part owner of like a car
dealership a nightclub that's at the
same time DMX is out there uh and it was
a lot of energy out there and I'm from
AZ so I gotta ask because I know you
were out there a lot yeah it was a lot
of energy
um
I liked it I mean I was from Philly man
so you know you have a you've been to
Philly you see I would I have I just
told Ness I've literally just rode a
train through Philly from DC to New York
and
and I was telling him how we stopped in
Chester at like one of the stops and I
looked outside and I was like what the
[__] where are we at right yeah well if
you ever go to Philly I mean it's some
nice Parts but
the majority of the parts is like a big
difference from Arizona so when I got
over there and I seen how people living
how nice it is
how dope it was and plus I'm out there
working on my music so I got a different
type of reception so I was loving it man
Swiss had the club I was performing
there was lit was turned what was it
like being around DMX during that era of
x
because that was like he was like in the
desert with them ATV he's heavy man yeah
I actually went back to Arizona too like
um for my third album when I after I
fought the case and I came home I
started working on a new project I went
to Arizona to do that before the
accident and
um that was the like the last time I was
like really around X went to his crib
um but Dr Benjamin to his house now Dr
Benjamin was in the belly movie with him
preaching to him and all of that so then
I'll bring him to X house and we all
vibing out chilling and um
it was dope man X was in a positive Zone
I was liking how he was I mean carrying
it at that time and one of the memorable
moments is when he showed me this giant
scorpion we was riding past he was on
the four wheeler we was in the car he
was leading us back out to the road to
leave and then he turned around he said
yo yo I want to see a scorpion and be
like yeah and he took a rock and he
threw it down and then like
made the Scorpion tail come off and he
picked it up like this and that poison
was Dripping in me like look look
and
that's that I heard his crib was like
like in Carefree like deep like
yeah that's how I remember them like he
was just like he ain't give a [__] about
nothing he was just wild
but good dude so that's your last memory
I mean remember with X and Arizona yeah
busting the Scorpion Stinger off and
yeah yeah with Dr Ben him and belly and
the whole vibe it was it was it was
super dope yeah man it's crazy because
you've uh you've been a part of some
historical movements in hip-hop bands so
it's dope to kind of see you get this
this Battle Run in you that's like
you're like one of the it Battlers now
and you're kind of like helping carry
the scene now so you know I feel like uh
it's just it's just good to see man for
you how are you adjusting because you've
been through so many eras of this music
[__] like how do you adjust
with the new wave with the a world in
which Tick Tock is a big part of what
breaks and you know there's not a you
you have more of a direct line of
communication with your fans now you
know what I'm saying like like or you
feel like you're adjusting to the new
era of this [__] like pretty well
yeah I mean I don't gotta adjust I'm
living through it yeah I mean so
and I'm not stuck in my ways like I'm
not stuck in the old ways or the old
form of darn business like I move
where however things are going yeah and
I got a team I got Sons you know I mean
Sons a son that's 19 a son that's 14
like they like super into technology and
the new waves and what's going on yeah
so they put me on I got a team myself
that I do music with that's all
different ages like you know I mean in
all different places in their life that
be putting me on so that's how I'm able
to stay on top of things and I make sure
I just stay on top of being dope and
being a rapper you got a team of people
that'll figure out how to stay on top of
Technology
for you give me your top five punchline
rappers ever let's exclude you because
you're in that I got you as top two I
told you but but who who's who's in the
five who got the best punch lines in
hip-hop history man outside of yourself
um love finesse
um
Big O of course
Big Daddy Kane and G Rap
yo Big Daddy Kane he said that [__] on
the Big L album where he was like uh
exhibit Styles I kick With It Part of me
but I'm [__] sick with it yeah
man for sure Daddy Kane is a legend man
that's like my I name dudes that like
kind of came
but for me that was my inspiration like
and I like took punch lines to the next
level like you never heard an artist
doing it like back to back like line
after line after line like before you
could I get one or two in a verse but
not you know yeah like it's everything's
kind of and um
like before you could dissect one punch
line you already getting into another
one and making them connect like they
never really seen rappers doing that but
my inspiration is what inspired me to
want to create that style and once I
created that I don't really think nobody
took it to her I leveled past that yet
so that's why I got a name to dudes that
came before me and inspired me hey we
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about the homies at my bookie
bet on anything anywhere anytime at
mybookie.ag and check this out if you
sign up right now with the keyword
bootleg you're gonna get a first deposit
bonus up to a thousand dollars and
that's not it
if you sign up with that keyword bootleg
not only will you get that first deposit
bonus up two thousand dollars but you're
also gonna get a free 50 000 sweet 16
bracket entry so many ways to win at
mybookie.ag I've been using them for
about 10 years now trust me when I say
I'm not co-signing them because they're
dropping the bag I mean that's nice but
I've been literally using my bookie for
the better part of the last decade to
put all my sports bets in to play a
little online roulette a little black
jack a little craps it's all there they
got the live casino they got so much
going on look March Madness is where
it's at right now you can get down with
that uh sweet 16 the elite eight the
NCAA Final Four all of it NBA season in
full effect baseball is about to kick
off get in on the action bet on anything
anytime anywhere right now with my
bookie so sign up at mybookie.ag use
that promo code bootleg right now for
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars and a free 50 000 sweet
16 bracket entry hey also shout out to
the homies at Bluetooth man don't forget
if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction in if your penis is not
functioning correctly it's a little
flaccid you're trying to get it a little
hard a lot of hard rather Bluetooth is
where it's at a lot of people ask me you
always talking about Bluetooth does it
work yes it works all right uh listen it
has the same active ingredient as Viagra
and a Cialis but it's in a chewable form
all right it is sent right to your door
uh in a discrete package it's a great
thing man go to bluetooth.com right now
you use that promo code bootleg right
now you're gonna get a month supply for
free of Bluetooth why not have some
better sex okay seriously uh there's so
many other ways you can get down too
because they just dropped the Bluetooth
mint flavor which is the same active
ingredient as Levitra just so many
things we can do here uh and look when
you go to bluetooth.com and you sign up
with that promo code bootleg they're
gonna literally send it straight to your
crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you will get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife will even never know it even
happened you know what I'm saying maybe
you've been a little embarrassed you're
tired of piping down that same old bra
that you've been sleeping with for the
last 35 years put a little pep in your
step man take a blue shoe use that promo
code bootleg bluetooth.com and try it
for free is there anybody from the newer
generation that you're just a fan of not
even on some punchline [__] just on some
rapper [__] like who who are you
listening to that that uh is from from I
guess the the current ERA if anybody
[Applause]
um I listen all that type of [__] man I
listen to everything
um money bag yo like one of my favorite
artists I like a bunch of his um he's
fire like you know I mean I like his
voice his style and [__] he be talking
about
but I like um even records like you know
I mean I'll be with my wife and with the
the women that's down with my team and
then it could be something like
come on I like that like I like
um and all that type of stuff man I'm in
all different type of bags I like all of
the new artists for different reasons
and just because they might not be
lyrical just because they might not be
this or that they might do other things
that I think is dope and I like you know
things go into 360. so I could see a lot
of artists that came before them in a
new version of the old artists that they
are so
I'm excited and I'm glad this [__]
growing is the number one form of music
in the world now period yep everybody
know what it is they know it's not a fad
that's gonna be here forever and a lot
of new artists finding different ways to
be successful in the same thing that we
call rap or hip-hop you know I mean you
don't got to be One Direction you don't
gotta just have bars or be street or be
killer it's like you could be
or even have information like you got
even Rappers that's not too smart that's
uninformed but figuring out a way to
get a fan base so it's dope yo I always
say that it's for me it's easy I
separate the art from the artist at all
times and one of the best R Kelly
features ever is obviously
hotel which is on your first album well
that was your first single right yes sir
um what was that process because I
always heard that R Kelly's like process
as an artist was like he was like a
savant Like Rain Man type [__] you know
what I'm saying like what was it like
did you guys do that in studio together
yeah so you get that was like you were
in the session with Kells as he's
cutting that what was that studio
session like
um
it was my first time eating them and um
I think it was my first time to Chicago
too so you guys went to Chicago yeah
and um you know Switzerland was telling
me you know different stuff or how it
might be but when we went in there I'm a
super fan of R Kelly me too like my
older brother that raised me like you
know we used to ride around in the hood
banging that like banging R Kelly songs
loud like
I was a super fan for sure so to know
that I'm working on my first album
finally got budgets open and it's like
big yeah and I'm working on my first
single with R Kelly and swiss beats
produced it and I think it's like so I
was excited I was super happy
um I got in the studio
um
and um even Twista came through I
remember twister came through the studio
and um me and Twista like start rapping
I think twist the spit some bars I spit
some bars
and um we basically me and swiss just
was there Swift started explaining the
record like hot was it swiss's idea to
do the hotel concept or was it R Kelly's
idea
um
yeah it was Swiss out there
it was like a collaboration it was a we
we already had the idea that we wanted
to do this hotel record when we went to
go see R Kelly so it was already like an
idea we had we already had the beat
and we already like had the direction a
little bit but once you told R Kelly
like the idea he just went crazy in his
own Direction and started singing a
bunch of stuff he went in the booth and
went crazy and started doing a lot of
things that we could have used for a
hook so he was just cutting Melodies off
the top of his head type [__] yeah we
just chose that little piece that you
know as the hotel core is now but he did
a lot of a lot of different parts and a
lot of different other versions of hooks
like we did the remix too off the same
session so it's just parts of the parts
that I told you he did that we didn't
use just for the remix but there's so
many ladies like he just went in
different bags he
creative man and [__] talented I forgot
to tell you too
before he went in the booth on the hotel
beat it was like a b tape playing of
like 30 beats just playing back to back
and he wouldn't say skip none of them he
wouldn't be like I don't like him or
nothing like that is
yeah it wasn't Swiss I don't know who
right but it was just a tape playing and
every beat that come on as soon as the
beat dropped he was singing a dope
record to it [__] sound like a Smash Hit
everyone I was like I was like right off
the top Hill he'll hear it while the
intro on as soon as the beat dropped he
starts singing some fire [__] like and
he did that [__] to Every Beat like he
kept doing it so I'm like yo this [__]
is not
um I think back to one of my favorite
records that was more like an album cut
you had a record called six minutes that
was it was you Wayne and Juelz right or
was it is that right I wish I got it oh
go back on the last question sorry I
wish I got a chance to like bust it up
with any more like release Jamar Kelly
yeah what type of Duty is because we
never really got a chance to what was
the video shoot like no it was the first
time I met him and then the second time
I met him was the video shoot yeah and I
never got a chance to meet him after
that yeah I really didn't like [__]
or kick like like kind of he did it feel
like he was kind of help like helping
Swiss out you know what I'm saying like
more like that yeah I mean it was my
first project I have no records out so I
really had nothing for him to really
right you know be connected to me it's
just I was connected to something big
which was full surface Swiss
um and then Jay records Clive Davis I
had to you know I mean were you one of
the first it was like You Alicia Keys
who else was on on Jay wasn't Baby
Records Mario was on J Records yeah I
feel like you were one of the first
people don't like I feel like it was I
feel like it was you or uh Alicia Keys
when I first saw saw Jay records pop up
yeah I was I was I was one of them you
know first
artist especially rappers yeah and I
mean yeah but you had I feel like I was
super excited because I had heard your
mixtape [__]
I heard you on some mix because I used
to sell mixtapes at the Swap Meet that's
how I got my name when I was like 15 16
so like
I remember just like there was I think
it was some funk Flex [__] you did
there was like a random Funk Flex
mixtape and he wasn't doing a lot of
mixtapes but it but you were you had a
verse on a mixtape that Flex was on or
something and I just yeah man I remember
just hearing like two or three me and my
best friend Ramses
man it was crazy too yeah he was super
prepared that was like battling in
Philly for years
um on this radio show called decipher so
by the time I got signed you was already
ready and then it took years for me to
actually go from getting signed because
I got signed a Rough Riders first when I
was 17.
and I ain't really come out with like my
first project till I was 21. so it was
like four years it's almost like rap
like like boot camp College yeah and
then you graduated exactly was there
ever any other big battles that you were
a part of that never got filmed or that
you know it back from that era where
you're like man if that would have been
on YouTube it would have went crazy yeah
thousands of them who else did you go up
against it you think you know I mean
obviously in hindsight it would have
been nice if you recorded them but
yeah I don't them battles that I did was
like over 20 years ago right so I don't
be liking to bring them up it was a long
time yeah I forgot about a lot of dudes
that damn holding away and then the ones
that did that I might remember some of
them is still like active trying to do
stuff or might have moved on and don't
want to bring that up so I don't really
wanna I rather somebody else do it yo I
was there and I seen cash kill this
person or
but it is tapes around and there's a
bunch of people that was there so I'd
rather just go like that
um I was I brought up that six minutes
record you had with Wayne you that
record came out right around the time
when I feel like Wayne was like
making that transition from being the
dude we knew from like the hot boys and
like lights out waiting to being like
Carter one Carter 2 Wayne where he
really kind of was like
finally getting rid because for a long
time I feel like people didn't give a
lot of the Cash Money guys respect as
rappers and then I think Carter won
changed that whole trajectory for Wayne
what was that record like because that's
a record where everyone's just kind of
going in
um
what what year was that was that 06
um oh six minutes when that game six
because that was on your second album
yeah so oh five yeah oh 506 so yeah
that's like legit like right after
Carter one so what was that like was it
did you guys get in for that was that
like a very competitive session
yeah me came through um I was in New
York and Wayne came through I was in the
studio with Fab a lot back then yeah you
know I mean [__] came through the studio
also an amazing punchline rapper some of
the greatest lines ever for sure like we
really locked in we we wasn't really
like sending records or nothing like
that like they came through the studio
we really locked in and made it happen
and I I was I was the one that put that
record together like it wasn't like a
label thing or something like that like
because you were tapped in with what was
going on with Wayne yeah and I knew
Wayne was
um rapping at the time and I knew that
Fab was rapping at the time so if all of
us came and went crazy like that no hook
I don't gotta even be about no hook
trying to make a hit record I know we
could do that that's easy but
just talking about spitting and I knew
that to make make a mark so that's why I
wanted to put that record together is
that a competitive session
like who's like I can only imagine
because you know nowadays people send
records out you hear a verse you put
your verse on it you send it back I
can't imagine all three of y'all in
there
just rapping yeah I think ever since I
came out
I just changed the trajectory of how
[__] was going like I made it more
competitive made you had to be more
lyrical made you have to have more punch
lines and lyrics and peace out more
syllables just to sound like you were
spitting right because before you ain't
have nothing else to compare it to but
when you could listen to me doing it
like this if you supposed to be lyrical
you gotta be doing it to a certain level
so around that time I came out you
started to see a lot of people change
more punch lines peace and no more
syllables changing they flow not trying
to be exactly like me but knowing that
you had to go in that direction and be
successful yeah for sure I mean you guys
also kicked I feel like there was that
wave after I'm a hustler where everybody
wanted that same type of hook yeah and
then bring them out came out because I'm
a hustler was first yeah but you kicked
off like a whole second wave of like
everyone hitting Swiss for like the
Jay-Z sample like hook yeah I'm a
hustler and I feel like it inspired a
lot like even the 50 record I get money
I get money like it's like the same
drums the same bounce the same beat the
same concept there's a lot of Records
like that yeah it might not have been a
hoe sample but there were like I feel
like that record kicked off a like a
little mini era for sure yeah for sure
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
Odd Socks baby that's right shout out to
Odd Socks little Godfather sock right
there craziest licenses in the game the
most comfortable socks period And if you
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws let's pop these boys open
check them out oh yeah oh yeah a little
Chun Lee versus Blanco
what
amazing
do you like Yoo-hoo so much that you'd
wear you who on your feet
there's people wandering around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
you who they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the both there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet
I promise you you gotta go to
autotoxofficial.com right now and use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off your
entire order all right so go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Harding the craziest
dispensary you've ever walked into in
your life Hardy in Las Vegas you got to
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you got to
stop off you got to go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Hardy underscore Las Vegas check out
more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview what is your writing process
like man because you are such a prolific
writer you come up with these Concepts
you come up with these bars that are so
[__] crazy so for you is this off the
top are you cutting Melodies first are
you in your phone writing like what is
your writing process like when you're
cutting records
um I've been writing for so long and I
make so many records All Above like I
could do it all I got
wild ammo on my phone my computer
um in my book bag I got like five rap
books
um
sometimes I never wrote I just kept it
in my head and went and laid it yeah
people not witnessed me do it all
different type of ways and because I'm
so active and try to stay on top of it
I'll be figuring that um
that's the best way to do it not just
one way like sometimes when I get the
time I like the right that's the best
way I feel like seeing actually what you
think about and writing it down is the
best process to me
but
um I wish a lot of these kids would
write more and not punch in because I
feel like when you write I feel like
there's something about that process
where you like the punching into it is
cool but I feel like
it's on the fly so you're really not
putting too much thought into each each
line like if it comes out cool it comes
out cool but I feel like when
[__] right like who who was on
our Show recently they said they stopped
punching and they started writing
somebody like once I started writing
like my [__] just got better got sharper
it was every line really I gotta write
it down like you know what I mean like
this whole generation they'd just be
punching in man you've been through so
many of a couple words say it you know
they were like what what's something
cool I could say here and then they go
to the next line you know I mean I was
gonna say this whole um well you
specifically man your career your life
you've been through so many Peaks and
valleys that we've got to witness as
fans what
um
has inspired you to
um just keep going man because you know
I feel like you've been through a lot
and a lot of the [__] you've been
through that we've got to see you go
through might break somebody or might
you know
throw a real fork in their career and it
feels like you're you're in your bag
right now it feels like you you're
really on top of your [__] I think the
reason why I started doing this I
started wanting a rat when I was super
young
before I had responsibilities I was
looking at it like a business I just
wanted to be the best right so that's
why I fell in love with it for bars for
lyrics and wanting to be the best and I
still got that passion to this day so a
lot of people be in it for business
reasons so when they find out how
sheisty this industry is how [__] up
the business is then it's like how can
you keep motivation if he was in it for
business and you find out how [__] up
the business is what's going to keep
what's going to keep you yeah what's
gonna keep you in it if you got in it
for the like look like the other rappers
or where the jury and you find out that
a lot of them [__] up a lot of the
jury fake or even the ones that's real
the Jewelers getting over on [__] and
you start finding out all the behind the
scenes details everything don't make you
had to drive like when you were kid and
uninformed but the reason why I wanted
to do it is still valid like I want to
be the best I like to impress people
with what I think about like
how I'm able to just come up with
thoughts write it down or say it and
impress people that's what I wanted to
be the best at so that's what motivate
me to keep going and no matter what I do
like no matter how much money I get no
matter what position I'm in or how my
life go I'ma still have the passion to
do that like wear this
um my career and I do it for a business
or it's just like a hobby something I do
for fun I'ma still always do it because
it's rooted in passion yeah that's like
that's like Kevin Durant always says man
I just want a hoop like I'd be I would
be hooping if I wasn't getting paid like
it's my love you know what I'm saying
for sure
um
music wise what do you got on the way
you are you all right because I know
you're you're you got the battle [__]
going crazy you just had it did you just
battle or you were at the Battle this
weekend did you have a battle this
weekend no I just was hosting I'm
hosting a lot of these events um hosted
the rbe event a smack event just hosted
this event create for you that they put
together
so I missed the podcast I'm doing media
I'm hosting to get more attention on
battle rap to make it better for the
battle rappers and for myself when I do
finally get back in battle
but um I ain't set up on the actual
battle the name yet to tell you but
um I'm in negotiations with a lot of
people so hopefully I have like at least
two battles this year hopefully fire but
what about are you or like on the music
tip are you working on anything
oh yeah my new project I feel like is
the best project of my life like this
new music I got this new wave I'm on
it's like I'm happy with it and I can't
wait to drop it I'm just
um and depending and doing everything
from the muscle and because I feel so
good about this project I just wanted to
be perfect so I got some little finish
and touches I got to put on it before I
release it but it's coming ASAP and it's
crazy I got the single already done we
gonna shoot the record of my um new
project today with Fred money out here
shout out to Fred money man yeah
it's um but um
I'm about to shoot another single real
soon grinding when we go back to Atlanta
but I think me living out the landing
and being in that new environment is
what got me like still spitting bars and
lyrical but the bounces and the flows
and the the bag I'm in is just like
different than you would expect to hear
from me especially a dude that's been in
it as long as me so I can't wait what's
your relationship with Swiss like these
days
still the same man that's my brother
um we not connected to hang out like we
used to you know what I'm saying but
people grow still communicating still
Tech still work you still give me advice
and we still like family got a lot more
connections other than me and swiss like
me and his pop me and his uncle is me
and
a bunch of people that's connected with
Swiss like and I mean it's so many years
that I've been tied up that I can't
really Separate Myself yo am I tripping
or was there a point in time you were
wrong with Carmelo Anthony
um yeah um after
I was I was with Swiss beats and J
Records right and I got um 1G records
fell apart was the last the last album
was bars on Jay right yeah yeah but when
like J Records broke down and Sony took
over and started doing all that stuff I
was out my major deal you know what I'm
saying because it was no more J Records
right
so that's when I felt the time to be
free I could go in the independent
Direction and I mean but
um
so if I was gonna go into independent
Direction I wanted to still do it big
but I needed investors so I felt like
basketball [__] was getting wild money
some of them be wasting it and throwing
it away it's not like I'm trying to blow
a lot of money I just need a certain
amount like if I was with a label to
make this project make sense so I
started thinking like yo I know
basketball players I know people
um
told mellow the plan wrote it out in
paperwork presented it to him and his
legal team and that's how we did the
deal but I wasn't signed to Mellow like
um people thought like in a traditional
way yeah it was more like him like a
record label like he was my CEO and I
was science he was an investor exactly
yeah that's what it was oh that's dope
shout out to Mellow it was so many
rappers who had or Amar'e Stoudemire had
a label
when uh who else
mellow KD had a label Katie's working on
an album with 38 special and um and
Ransom right now it's crazy when you see
guys like like uh I think all these
Sports dudes let's get into the bag
shaft labels man why not no make these
artists you know
be able to get loans or invest like you
know get the opportunity to get the
loans they need to be successful from
different places other than what's
available now when you see guys like 38
special and Ransom who have also had 15
years plus in the game
and they've been able to kind of have a
Renaissance of their career where
they're connecting and building these
like hardcore fan bases like there's
that [__] when you see [__] like like do
you pay attention to those guys and like
kind of because they're I feel like
those guys in their business model
something that even like the Griselda
business model is something that like
you know a lot of artists can kind of
take note and take advantage of because
you have some hardcore fans for sure and
you got fans who would put the money up
if you if I just was with them in the
house um last night 38 Special so
yeah yeah I got to change the meeting we
was in the house together he had a show
and
um event out there last night y'all
gotta get a record in man for sure
that'd be crazy who's on the new project
that's almost done that project's not
finished yet right yeah and almost the
feature's not done okay okay like the
main major features I'm gonna get at the
end you know that's when you gotta shake
and move to make it make sense so I
don't want to shout them all out but I
got records with ens already try to see
the block captain from Philly yeah
little flip drag on JAG from South
Central O'Hare Jack's hard money
um wait you've been working with Jack
for a long time yeah for sure
I feel like I heard a Jag like I told no
I did hear Jack through you yeah for
sure yeah I think I told him that too I
was like bro you're the same Jack who
used to roll with Cassidy he was like
yeah man yeah go gang man Mayhem music
lost any family he been down forever so
I got a record with him and Jag on the
project this kid named Poison Ivy
singing the chorus is like a single big
big record fire fire uh all right well
look uh hopefully you get a couple
battles in before the end of the year
would you ever consider launching your
own battle League
nah like it was a uh I came out here to
host the battle I told you about
daylight was battling this MMA fighter
named King bao but they put together a
pretty nice card and a bunch of the
battle rappers ain't even show up so the
main battles that people really wanted
to see on the pay-per-view couldn't even
go down because the battle rappers ain't
show up but they already got advances
they already know book flights
yeah it's like man and I can't take it
like how some of these League owners do
and might blog about it or be like going
back and forth It's like man
if I spend my money and I make something
happen [__] Gotta definitely be there
it was going to be like issues I'm just
not cut for doing that yeah I'd rather
play with other people money like I'm
out here I'm giving back to the coach
I'm the energy like the biggest thing
that happened with this event so far was
the face-offs I did but
I want to get my energy back but not
feel no type of way when I hear about
artists not coming out like because it's
not my event I didn't invest it's like
it's [__] up for the culture but I
don't feel as bad because I'm not losing
right right right you're like hey yo I
got my I'm I'm good yeah yeah
and even when these other leagues book
me it's a big event for the undercar
battle is that's coming under me they
get an opportunity but it's not my money
so however it go is how it go I just
know what I'ma Do you know what I'm
saying so
I would have to get a different type of
um bag
um myself or a different type of
investors or something like that to be
able to pull something like that off but
I wouldn't invest my own money into
starting a league yeah well listen man I
appreciate you pulling up your Legend
bro thanks for having me we're gonna
have your freestyle too but we're gonna
do a separate YouTube video for that uh
new music soon new music ASAP ASAP go
follow them online man Cassidy
appreciate you brother thanks for having
me